[Music]
reese's in tampa florida hi theresa how
are you
hi i'm great thank you and rachel for
taking my call i appreciate it
sure how can we help um i have a
question i work for
a very small company there are seven
employees i'm a geriatric care manager
and i make about 40 000 a year
and i had a client that passed away a
couple of months ago
and out of the blue her family sent me
a check written out to me as a gift
they said it was a small token of their
appreciation for
taking care of their loved ones and it's
for five thousand dollars
wonderful that's a lot that's a lot of
money for me but
um our company doesn't have a policy
against gifts or about monetary gifts so
my boss is trying to figure out
what she wants me to do i have sent an
email
to the person that gave it to me and
said thank you so very much i really
appreciate it but
you know i don't feel like i can accept
this money but they
are insisting that i keep it good they
should
and it's none of your boss's business if
he doesn't have a policy
well that's kind of my question i i have
um
in in my heart if they insist that i
keep it if i can't get out of it
um i have definitely some charities that
i wanted to go to
and some things that i know were near
and dear to my client's heart
teresa no no
you're supposed to have this money you
served these people
and they were grateful you're supposed
to enjoy this money
you don't need to feel guilty you didn't
do anything wrong
have you ever gone to a restaurant and
left a tip that was a really nice tip
for somebody that gave you a great did a
great job waiting on a table
as much as i can do i know but if you
left if you left a nice tip where you
were kind of like that was a good tip
yeah did you want that person to feel
guilty and go give it to a charity
because they didn't deserve it no they
deserved it they waited on your table
and did a good job
and you were honoring them and it
honored you to be able to do that to
give them that tip
don't mess this up this was for you you
did
great this is an atta girl well
thank you for that i just i i not only
feel guilty i also my boss has been
kind of mentioning different ways she
thinks it ought to be spent
i don't care what he thinks it's not his
money it's not her money
it was made out to you right from this
family
yes okay now if i am your boss
if i am your boss i am going to be not
with you
but this raises a question in the
business that you all are in
if i'm leading this organization i think
he should or she should put a policy in
place
that limits gifts because we don't want
the caregivers that people are paying
for with our company
to get wrong motivations where they try
to snuggle up with the
person they're taking care of in order
to get money
and we don't want this to turn toxic you
didn't do that
but if i'm in your business i want to
make sure the caregivers are not
being toxic in order to uh you know try
to get some sugar daddy that's the
boss's problem though yeah but
that and that's their problem and this
just makes them recognize that but they
don't get a vote this is your money
absolutely i mean and i want you to
enjoy it if you want to give a little
bit of it
mac i'll give you a maximum no more than
500 the other 4 500
has to be spent to further your life and
your income
this was for you teresa
part of part of the art of giving is
also learning to receive
and it's very hard for some folks to
receive but this is for you
please don't give it away it is
dishonoring to the people that sent it
to you
if they wanted it to go to the ministry
that support a ministry that the person
that died
they would have given it to that
ministry they didn't give it to them
they gave it to you
and considering they wrote you a check
thanking you
they probably have been giving elsewhere
they're probably a family of givers and
they probably said wow you took care of
my mom that
my mom loved theresa she probably you're
hurt that that woman you took care of
probably talked about you teresa all the
time to her family
when she passed they said we want to
bless teresa because she blessed us so
you're good
you're good you're good that's it and
and
we've had the pleasure as ramses to do
that kind of thing many times and we
fully expect it to go to you
and i you know if i if i were on this
family side
uh i would be telling you the exact same
thing and by the way they are
telling you the exact same thing i'm
telling you
you keep it and no it's not your bosses
and know your boss doesn't get a vote if
your boss wants to put a policy in place
for future things
then that's okay they can do that and
that might not be a
bad idea and to kind of help ease the
the pain for you teresa of taking this
five thousand dollars
you know we will say like if someone
gets a big inheritance or a grandparent
leaves a chunk of money to a grandson or
granddaughter whatever the case says
we do say yeah there's a level of you
can honor their legacy really well and
use this money maybe to pay off debt or
to save or
or to do something great to further your
life you can just go spend it i don't
care
but for you to ease that a little bit
maybe you say you know what i'm going to
help
pay down my car and start working my way
to get out of debt whatever the case is
whatever you do with it think of the
lady that you cared for
is she smiling when you're doing that
with that money
and then you know you're honoring her
legacy she's in heaven watching you
and she's smiling she probably is
already smiling about this conversation
you're awesome theresa you have a sweet
sweetheart